I love it well I know I asked that
questions so often I'm that kind of
crazy guy I'm a sci-fi fan you know
anything is possible of the imagination
so it never hurts to dream impossible
dreams and just never might you might
never know they might come true so I
believe that if I had any possible
superpower there's only one superpower I
would really really really want that
would be on the top of that list and to
me the it's the only thing and this is
why the almost more spiritual sense it's
very profound because I think the time
is so precious that so much of us waste
time thinking about the past of what
already happened and not really focusing
on where you are in the present moment
but I would to have the total control
over time because that's really my only
anything is that I just wish I had more
time to read to write letters to friends
to express express gratitude to say
thank you to plan to vision to sleep um
to time if I had more time I feel like I
could be doing so much more but it makes
it even more important to me not to
count the days or hours but to make
every hour and day count and yeah so
understanding that it makes life a
little more meaningful there's a lot of
insight actually exactly because
especially if you give them choices and
see what they choose I I have to say I
know i annoy friends and strangers alike
you never want to sit next to me on an
airplane I warn you right now it's hell
for anybody who is trying to read or
sleep or something like that I really do
have this and this is before I got into
politics or anything like that I just
think people aren't amazing and
everybody has a story everybody is a
gift from God I don't believe that there
are mistakes and if somebody ends up
sitting next to you when you encounter
them it's just a one there are such a
wonderful being we all are so I just
love folk and
and I just like people when I observe
other people you know what we always
should affirm the other person's
humanity and just recognize their
humanity no matter who they are and
something I like to do but I'm also just
a very curious guy and so conversation
to be sometimes as much as I say comfort
people are interesting and fascinating
conversations often get boring to me
it's like I don't want to talk about the
weather
I don't want to talk about you know the
the most recent sports game unless of
course it's a giant Super Bowl victory
but let's talk about something that
really matters and often hypothetical
questions are portals to understanding
deeper idealistic and value-based
proposition so you know I often ask
people if you had a button in front of
you and you could push the button and
you would get a billion dollars for
pushing that button I mean a billion
dollars you could cure diseases in
places you could save lives build wings
to hospitals and so and so forth but we
on the planet someplace somewhere
somebody you don't know would die would
you push the button well what if that
person was in jail and death row or what
if that person was only had a month to
live anyway and you know you find out
people's value system and often the
problem is and I think this is something
that I my parents gave me as a good gift
is that we don't think time is people to
even check ourselves and what are my
values let me pull out a journal and
just say what is important to me as a
person what are the ideals I'm committed
to live for what are the things I'm
willing to die for and so doing games
whether there are superhero questions or
pushing button questions that are value
clarification opportunities where you
could affirm who you are I enjoy that
it's silly I'm weird but in many ways
this this country was founded on people
with insane ideals and values that at
first are viewed as heresy or Nexus
viewed as a radical and they're soon as
refuses orthodoxy